politicians or something and not in
their Prime Nikki Haley isn't in their
Prime sorry when a woman is considered
being a prime in her 20s and 30s and
maybe 40s that's not according to me
Prime for what it depends I mean it's
just like Prime if you look it up it'll
if you look if you Google when is a
woman in her prime it'll say 20s 30s and
40s I'm just saying Nikki Haley should
be careful about saying that politicians
are not in their Prime and they need to
be in their Prime when they serve
because she wouldn't be in a prime
according to
Google Google or whatever it is good
morning everyone Audi cordesh is here at
the desk with us this morning Don has
the day off